[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by mason dye aka
jason in stranger things season four we
are talking spoilers for season four
volume one so make sure you watch that
first before you watch this interview
mason how you doing today man
i'm doing great how are you doing
i'm doing great i was so excited to talk
to you you're one of my favorite new
characters on the show
so
oh no problem man and your acting is so
much part of that it really is one of
the best performances even put in the
show to date so
really cool that you're here today so
was jason always the character you were
going to play or did you audition for
anybody else
no i
auditioned for jason that
was the only one i'd gone in for that uh
so it was yeah jason from the start
oh interesting so
when you got that part as jason was that
anxiety inducing for you being put on
such a big project to stranger things
uh yes 100 it was like
it was funny because yeah the audition
process was
probably like three three and a half
months long and then
when i got it i i had probably like one
day of uh
[Music]
like being excited about it and then it
woke up the next morning and then it
just like hits you all at once that
you're about to go on
one of the biggest shows ever and uh
is
so nerve-wracking so much anxiety
leading up to filming it was uh it was a
lot to say the least
so does that like nerves and anxiety
with your performing does that come into
play meaning like even when we first see
you this season you're making this great
speech at the basketball game but you're
also as an actor performing in front of
a lot of peers that are very very
big and successful is that
nerve-wracking do you toss and turn the
night before before your big moments
you know
yes yes and no the
so by the time we actually got to
all the speeches
um
you know coveted hit so
we
we couldn't film in like large crowds
so all the speeches were actually at the
end of filming so
um by the time we actually got around to
filming those i already felt like really
comfortable on set and that's one thing
that stranger things like
the cast the crew
everybody involved makes you feel so at
home
and so welcome
um
so by the time we got to those scenes i
i was pretty comfortable
um
but i mean it's always nerve-wracking
when you are speaking in front of
how however many people that was like
300
but uh because i yes i was
first take of both of the speech
speeches the town hall and the
pep rally
uh definitely shaky definitely
yeah like public speaking i hate public
speaking
and it's funny because yeah once uh
i didn't really know my role when i got
cast i didn't know
um any of the scenes or anything like
that just like very brief of of who
jason was
um
but when i got those speeches i was
terrified absolutely
but yeah but
by the time we got to filming it it
definitely became a lot easier
yeah and i could see that tara coming in
and you don't show it at all on screen
you do an amazing job and but i could
see where as an actor you're heavy load
here in these two scenes like these are
your moments so it's like you brought it
though which is good i appreciate it
because yeah deep down
deep down there's terror for sure
no but it's great and for you though
even like having now the season's first
half being out was it a sigh of relief
for you to see critics and fans loving
the season like do you feel like more
comfortable now i feel like there's like
a weight off your shoulders kind of oh
for sure for sure because uh
i don't know it's just interesting
whenever you're filming it you're
having so much fun doing it uh that you
really don't think about the response
that people are gonna have and it's not
until you finish
that you start to think oh no
like
people love this uh but no it was
such a relief um to see that fans and
critics are enjoying it as much as they
are
totally and you're a big part of that
and now was there any other you know
characters from other films or tv that
kind of inspired your portrayal of jason
like when you're kind of getting down to
figuring out how you're gonna play him
oh yeah yeah definitely um
so before
like i said like i i didn't know much
about jason
or
who jason was before filming
um
and then i sat down with the duff duffer
brothers and sean levy
and uh they're like okay
um
jason is
i'll say it it doesn't matter jason is
just tom cruise from his 80s 80s movies
i love that
so yeah so i uh i just went back i
watched uh like risky business top gun
just like all his 80s movies like a week
prior to filming
um and just tried to hone this uh
like my version on uh tom cruise tom
cruise if he goes through these events
and then also tom cruise if you went to
church like
six times a week
no mason that is incredible because i
literally had a question lined up where
i was like if you search mason dye or
jason there's a lot of people saying tom
cruise energy so you totally
came for that and are there
fans oh yeah oh yeah so that's why it's
so funny you said that
that's so fun
people caught on to it because uh
i didn't know when i was doing it i was
like i don't think anyone's going to be
able to tell
that uh
i'm cruising it right now but uh and
that is so funny that people are saying
that i love that i love that hell yeah
you bring that superstar energy man
that's awesome yeah
it tom cruise was the perfect person to
model him after it was
it was great i'm like i love that they
gave that note i love that people are
picking it off that's that's so funny
yeah and what's interesting too about
people talking about the character of
jason is like he's clearly an antagonist
in the season but there's a lot of
people who sympathize with him and see
his story where some people are just
like no he's a jerk like when you're
portraying him though as an actor do you
have to kind of see the sympathetic side
more
uh you have to i think uh because the
the actor's job like you'll hear it a
lot it's uh
you can't you can't judge your character
uh you you have to fully buy into what
they're selling and what they're
believing so
um
whenever you read it for like i remember
when i read it the first time through
without being him it's like i obviously
see the audience perspective but then
once
you start to dive into it once you play
them you just have to fully commit to
understand why this guy is doing what
he's doing
um
so yeah i definitely playing him you
have to empathize completely once
i was done with a character and i get to
watch it back then i could watch it as
like an audience member and just be like
like
just be it yeah just be a jerk
but but that i think is one thing like a
testament to the duffel brothers what i
think
they did such a good job with jason
was
writing that line of being like yes you
obviously have this antagonist going
throughout the story uh
and hunting down these kids and just
doing terrible things but then also
um
giving the audience reason to believe
not believe but just see why he's doing
what he's doing
because i don't think jason is a
character he's definitely not a
character that's meant to be liked he's
just meant to be
understood
and
like understanding his actions
throughout even though he goes about it
in a terrible way
like he's just like
he's the worst
uh but but that's also just like it's
such a fun role to play
yeah
it was a blast
yeah and i think what's interesting too
about jason's character is the
relationships he has and
one i think very people are very
interested in is the rivalry between him
and eddie uh did you and joseph keep
that kind of energy and tone on set are
you guys kind of like buddy buddies
uh no not at all we are
bloody buddy okay
there's no picking on each other on set
or anything like that
yeah it was hard uh it was actually
really hard trying to do that stuff with
him
um
i'm just thinking because i i really
don't have like
in the first volume like what people
have seen
um
we don't have a lot of
screen time together
um
but i just remember the first time i
really got to like go face to face with
him was
um
in the cafeteria where he like pops up
on the table and he's doing his like
such a great scene where he's calling
her like going like the party people all
this stuff joe quinn is incredible when
he looked over and he's like
laundry and uh
or whatever the laundry basket slime
that he has and then we stand up and
have that i call him a freak yeah like
so many times in this
but uh i remember when we did that
i couldn't stop laughing because every
time i would stand up i would just like
break
and
see it when they're like zoomed in on
that clothes
three available uh three weeks before
filming
that we were staying in the same hotel
um and we would just hang out like all
day every day
we'd go see movies we'd go out to eat
we'd go on dates we went to the zoo
so it uh yeah joe quinn we did not keep
up the
same energy as you see on tv now that's
good so your true pros that you can get
in and out of that i like that now also
another relationship that's complicated
and interesting this season is the one
with
jason and lucas so
what was that like also with like caleb
in that you're this hawkins basketball
squad like did they have you guys
actually play any actual basketball
games can you play basketball well like
how was that whole thing
yes so yeah that's funny no they did
they actually we practiced
quite a bit uh with the whole uh all the
basketball stuff and um
they they took it very seriously uh
which was so much fun because that's
like
you want to like you want to like dive
into that stuff any like physical thing
that he does like you want to be able to
get good and also sell it because
there's nothing worse i've played sports
growing up and there's like nothing
worse than watching uh people play
sports on tv and then they don't know
how to do it
and
it's kind of obvious so yeah no they put
us in a lot
um
did tons of basketball practices
uh but no i didn't so i stopped playing
basketball in like
the third grade or something
so but in the audition process they
asked us they're like hey
can you play basketball and i was just
like oh yeah i was like yeah
he told him i think we told him that i
started on my high school basketball
team and i didn't even play high school
basketball but uh yeah yeah definitely
lied
see that's a good lesson for people yep
yeah
you got to do we got to do and figure it
out later um
so as a fan of the show yourself
do you have a
favorite episode of season four that you
could kind of say
yes
um
i mean it's tough that's tough because
episode four
i love episode four
the whole sequence with max that is just
stranger things just doing stranger
things it's like that was so cool to
watch but
i think i gotta go episode seven episode
seven to me like
almost two hours long and it didn't it
didn't lose me one bit i was glued to
the screen
everything about episode seven worked so
well so i think
episode seven might be my favorite
episode of the whole series
wow wow
i love that and there's a lot of people
who agree with that and those are
definitely two best episodes of season
so it's really cool to hear you say that
now
you can totally tell me to screw off and
not answer this question but no spoilers
obviously but can you maybe give us a
one or two word tease for volume two of
season four maybe a little adjective
noun
yeah let me think
let me think
will we like it
oh
you will love it you will 100 love it uh
i'm just trying to i'm trying to watch
my words like i read i read something
before just of like what i can't say
how about this
earlier
the last two episodes
insane as a so as a fan of the show
going into it this was like my favorite
show before i got on it it's like i've
always loved stranger things these last
two episodes to me
will be up there with episode seven
episode four
okay that's amazing to hear because on
my head i'm like how do you even go near
that how do you top that but if you're
saying it can live up to that that's
exciting um so
mason thank you so much for joining me
today
everybody obviously keep watching
stranger things volume one with mason as
jason he absolutely crushes it here and
also
make sure to tune in to volume two
coming out july first mason thank you so
much for joining me today i'll talk to
you in the future one day yeah thank you
so much for having me it's been a blast